Mother's Day marks an awkward time of
year for those on the hard left first
there are those who deny the value of
motherhood Cecile Richards of Planned
Parenthood tweeted nothing says I love
you mom like standing up for the rights
of mothers everywhere to get the care
they need by this presumably Sherman
abortion Planned Parenthood performs
hundreds of thousands of abortions every
year but there is one thing that says I
love you mom more than providing
abortion care maybe some aren't aborted
it turns out that in order for the
Appalachian mother to have any meaning
children must actually be part of the
process then there are those people on
the Left who believe the childbearing
and child-rearing aren't central to the
female mission that checking accounts
receivable is more socially and
individually rewarding in this category
we could put Ivanka Trump who tweeted
about the wage gap on Mother's Day even
though the only true reason for the
difference in overall earnings between
men and women is attributable to
motherhood it turns out that it may be
work families foregoing mom doing extra
work at the office if she can spend more
time at home with the kids there's
nothing wrong with that in fact it's
worth celebrating but the fun or lack
thereof doesn't stop there for the
radical left we still haven't tell what
- cisgender nature of Mother's Day how
could we suggest that women have
anything special to celebrate when men
can be women after all dove has run an
ad with a transgender woman explaining
what motherhood means to him a columnist
for the Toronto Star Emmett I tell wrote
this week that Mother's Day should we
ditched in favor of guardians day since
quote gendered holidays are painful an
exclusionary and a drag for non-binary
parents who don't identify with a single
gender title says quote a guardian can
be a mom a dad a non-binary parent to
grandparents and aunts and uncle a pet
owner or why the heck not somebody who
takes really good care of his house
plans but we're still not done how about
gay couples what about children with two
daddies one Canadian school has
reportedly ditched Mother's Day and
Father's Day because they are not
sufficiently inclusive the
administration announced via a letter
quote in an effort to celebrate
diversity inclusivity and also nurture
our students who are part of
non-traditional families we've decided
to encourage those celebrations to take
place at home so we've already done away
with apple pie far too much sugar for
those growing kitties and now we're
doing away with motherhood so we have
any values in common anymore fortunately
most Americans still reject the
stupidity
mothers are still mothers motherhood
still has inherent in beautiful value my
wife's a doctor which means she does the
most important work there is but she
believes her most important role is as a
mother to our two children and she's
right it's amazing that our society has
become so jaded about the value of
motherhood
willing to overthrow it in favor of
gender in
sensitivity as well as increasing
women's hours in the workplace I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
another day in more chaos we certainly
picked the wrong week to stop sniffing
glue around here we'll get through all
of that in just a second but first want
to say thank you to our advertisers over
at blue apron so if you are somebody who
enjoys an excellent fresh meal you're
sick of going to restaurants where they
pile on all the salt and they pile on
all the calories and then they
overcharge you for it blue apron calm is
the best way to eat it is the cleanest
and best way to eat the way that it
works is that you sign up for blue apron
calm slash capiro and they send you
recipes the fantastic gourmet recipes
with all of the ingredients that are
freshly chosen if they're not fresh then
you can return it and they won't make
you pay for it obviously they also made
these recipes are top-notch I mean
here's some give you a different recipe
every night when you subscribe it's beef
teriyaki stir-fry with sugar snap peas
and lime rice for example and you cook
it they send it to you you cook it all
the ingredients premade for you all of
the all of the recipes preset out for
you it's as easy as just following the
steps on the recipe and make sure that
everyone can cook together which is
awesome
research shows that blue apron families
actually cook three times more often
than everybody else those who spend a
lot of restaurants are at high-end
grocery change can now spend under that
under ten bucks per person for a
delicious meal again it's like baked
spinach and egg flatbread with sauteed
asparagus and lemon aioli crispy salmon
and roasted potato salad with pickled
mustard seeds and creme fraiche sauce
don't even know what that is but it
sounds awesome here's the thing all of
these recipes are high-end recipes that
you'd be getting at a top-notch
restaurant except you're cooking it
yourself it's affordable again under $10
per person per meal variety variety of
new recipes every week if you don't like
a recipe they won't repeat it recipes
are not repeated within a year so you
never get bored you know for my family
we have the same thing every Tuesday
except via blue apron you don't have to
do that anymore you get something brand
new every single day and they have that
freshness guarantee promising that every
ingredients in your delivery arrives
ready to cook or they will make it right
blue apron , slash Shapiro you'll love
how good it feels and taste to create
these incredible home-cooked meals with
blue apron blue apron comm slash Shapiro
when you use the slash Shapiro yet the
first three meals free with free
shipping again blue apron calm slash
apparel make sure you use the Shapiro
they know that we sent you okay so there
are two narratives that have now been
building up over the last 24 hours
it's we really need to do two shows a
day now because the news is breaking so
fast and so furious so yesterday late in
the afternoon the New York Times breaks
a piece that essentially claims that
Donald Trump said to outgoing FBI
director fired FBI director James Comey
back in February that he wanted him to
shut down the investigation into former
national security adviser Michael Flynn
is according to the New York Times and
it's kind of a bombshell for reasons
that we'll talk about so it says
president from the New York Times
reporting and before everyone goes over
New York Times fake news segment okay
we're confirmed by a bunch of other
mainstream media outlets you don't get
say fake news until something is shown
to be fake news okay let's just simple
rule you don't get say fake news until
the evidence the preponderance of the
evidence shows that it is fake news I
don't have to it doesn't have to be
beyond reasonable doubt preponderance of
the evidence okay so let's put this fake
news label aside just cuz the New York
Times reported it doesn't mean that we
get to pretend that nobody that
everything they say is a lie everything
I say is biased but not everything they
say is a lie and you'll see that in this
piece so it says President Trump asked
FBI director James Comey to shut down
the federal investigation into mr.
Trump's former national security adviser
Michael Flynn in an oval office meeting
in February according to a memo mr.
Comey wrote shortly after the meeting I
hope you can let this go the president
told mr. Comey according to the memo the
documentation of mr. Trump's request is
the clearest evidence that the president
has tried to directly influence the
Justice Department an FBI investigation
into links between mr. Trump's
associates and Russia late Tuesday
representative jason Chaffetz the
Republican chairman of the House
Oversight Committee demanded that the
FBI turn over all quote memoranda note
summaries and recordings of discussions
between mr. Trump and mr. Comey such
documents mr. Chaffetz wrote would quote
raised questions as to whether the
president attempted to influence or
impede the FBI mr. Comey wrote the memo
detailing his conversation with the
president immediately after the meeting
which took place the day after mr. Flinn
resigned according to two people who
read the memo was part of a paper trail
mr. Comey created documenting what he
perceived as the president improper
efforts to can influence a continuing
investigation
an FBI counts agents contemporaneous
notes are widely held up in court as
credible evidence of conversations
apparently he shared the existence is
the memo of senior FBI officials and
close associates the New York Times is
not viewed
copy of the memo which is unclassified
but one of mr. commis associates read
parts of it to a Times reporter so
apparently he said I hope you can see
your way clear to letting this go to
letting Flynn go Trump told Comey he's a
good guy I hope you can let this go
Trump told Comey Flynn had done nothing
wrong according to the memo so they're a
couple problems with this one is we
haven't seen the memo yet so people who
are saying well this is awful awful
awful again let's see the memo first
that's number one number two do I
believe that the memo is real yeah I do
because I think the Comey probably
created the memo specifically to create
a bureaucratic paper trail this is what
career bureaucrats like James Comey do
and I think that this is commis revenge
on Trump so two narratives have been
generated by this narrative number one
is coming from the left narrative number
two is coming from the right and they
are not mutually exclusive it's a
narrative number one coming from the
left is Trump is incompetent Trump's a
buffoon or Trump is nefarious and evil
and impeach evil and the case that
they're making basically is that here is
a chain of events if you're a leftist
and you're watching this or you remember
the mainstream media and you're watching
all of this unfold here is the logic
that you are using in your head we're
going to go through it and explain why
it's flawed but here's what you think if
you're on the Left here's what you think
from the chain of events lots of rumors
in the election cycle about Trump being
in cahoots with Russia Trump is very
nice to Russia the whole time then over
the objections pretty much everybody
right and left he appoints National
Security Advisor Mike Flynn to that
position to National Security Advisor
despite the fact it's pretty widely
known Nick Flynn has some nefarious ties
with the Russians right that's all
confirmed that's all Mon then Flynn ends
up being fired for reasons that remain
sort of unclear he ends up being fired
by the Trump administration Trump says
it's because Flynn lied to Mike Pence
about a phone call that he had with
Sergei Kissel II asked the Russian
ambassador but that's not super credible
we still don't really know why Mike
Flynn was fired by Trump it may have
just been Trump got sick of him he was
tired of the controversy undecided too
often but here again is the chain of
events from the left
Trump is quote-unquote in cahoots with
Russia this is their background and if
you're starting with that background
which by the way there's no proof of is
idea then the rest of this all looks
like obstruction of justice so looks
like he appointed Flynn Flynn has to be
fired because Flynn is dirty and then
the day after Trump goes to James Comey
and says I need you to stop your
investigation or I hope that you can see
your way clear to
doing this investigation into Flynn and
then Comey doesn't stop the
investigation into Flynn and then Trump
fires him two months later right that's
what the chain of events looks like it
looks like February there's this
conversation and by May Flynn Flynn is
gone and Trump is firing Comey and then
Trump is lying about why he fired Comey
he's sending out people to say that it's
all because of the Hillary investigation
they call me botched and then he goes on
national TV and he says well really I
was kind of getting sick of all this
Russia stuff and so he had to fire James
Comey so if all those things were true
then it looks like obstruction of
justice right it looks like Trump was
trying to fire the FBI director in order
to get him to stop the investigation
into contacts between members of trumps
team like Mike Flynn and the Russians
and that's why this is such a bombshell
report and this is the case that the
left is trying to make and they've
jumped on this with both feet today so
Sally ate because remember was Deputy
Attorney General who well actually be
acting Attorney General at this time who
warned President Trump about Mike
Flynn's quote/unquote nefarious ties
with the Russians she was on TV
yesterday saying that Mike Flynn was a
national security threat and we felt
like a national security threat
absolutely okay so she says that Flynn
was a national security threat obviously
and so the Democrats have jumped on this
to basically say Flynn was a national
security threat Trump wanted to kill the
investigation he told Comey he wanted
the investigation killed and then he
fired combing some structure of justice
and here is every Democrat and media
member in the world using that phrase
obstruction of justice the reason
they're saying obstruction of justice is
because obstruction of justice is quote
unquote impeachable right it did the
quote obstruction of justice is a high
crime or misdemeanor
it looks like the president's doing
something bad and that means that
Congress has the grounds to impeach now
we'll talk about whether Congress would
do that in any case in a second the
answer is no but the Democrats are
trying to make the case for impeachment
but not because they think he's going to
get impeached but because they want to
make it a 20-18 issue so here's all
these Democrats saying obstruction of
justice this and obstruction of justice
that Trump are asked are call me
according to news reports you just
mention it are to stop the investigation
of general Flynn which is kind of the
definition of what obstruction of
justice allegation that the president
may have engaged in some interference or
obstruction of the investigation
I think we know enough now there's been
enough alleged publicly to want to bring
the director back to testify ideally an
open session either before our committee
or the Judiciary Committee but he should
come back to the Congress and share what
he knows in terms of the president's
conversations with him okay so bottom
line is that if you're a Democrat you
already think Trump is guilty now you
think Trump is more guilty and you think
it's obstruction of justice now before
everybody on the right goes well they're
crazy because there's no actual fire
here which is true there's no actual
fire here before everybody on the right
goes crazy what's imagined that the
situation reversed and Barack Obama
there have been rumors about him
colluding with the Russians during the
2012 election and then after that he
there's an investigation into his
associates and their ties to Russia and
then he told the FBI director it would
be great if he dropped this and then he
fired the FBI director you think the
right might be crying bloody murder they
would so before we suggest that this is
utterly uncredible outside the bounds of
reason the reason I'm saying this folks
is because I think it's important we
were able to have a conversation about
what's true and false instead of
immediately leaping to the partisan
battle line so this is why the Democrats
are making this claim Nancy Pelosi is
saying this too she says the Trump is
unfit for office there many facets to
this as you know the president is he fit
to be President of the United States
when he would do such a thing it was
other takes on it but over 20 years of
experience as a top Democrat on
intelligence or as a leadership of the
gang of eight and this is a this is a
dedication you really have to read your
stuff no you have to watch me terrible
because obviously when she does unfit
for office the first thing we all think
is you're Nancy Pelosi you don't get to
talk about unfit for office but there
are very few Republicans who are out
there defending Trump yesterday because
there's not enough information to defend
him yet so Brett Baier on Fox News last
night he said we kept trying to find
Republicans to come on and defend Trump
on this Comey stuff and we got nothing
we've tried tonight to get Republicans
to come out and talk to us and there are
not Republicans willing to go on camera
tonight as of yet and we'll see if that
changes okay so narrative number one is
the narrative from the left and that is
Trump is fundamentally unfit for office
and that is either true because he is
purposefully obstructing justice or
because he's stupid enough to say things
to look like obstruction of
now my own take on this is number one
there is no fire as to the Trump Russia
stuff there's no evidence of collusion
between Trump and Russia there's not
even evidence of collusion between
Trump's campaign team and Russia at this
point and this is wildly overblown
obviously beyond that if Trump did say
to call me if you could see your way
clear to dropping this that'd be great
does that necessarily constitute
obstruction of justice not really
because Trump says lots of dumb things I
mean Trump says lots of silly things all
the time and he's very casual on his
language and this is sort of the problem
with Trump is you don't know when to
take him seriously and when not to take
him seriously which leads to narrative
number two and this is a narrative from
the right so the narrative from the left
today is Trump obstructed justice and
now it's impeachable narrative from the
right is this is all a witch-hunt
there's nothing here everybody is out to
get Trump and this is all crazy towns
it's all part of a broader effort by the
intelligence community to take down
Trump this is all part of a broader
effort by the media to take down Trump
this is all part of a broader effort by
the Democrats to take down Trump and
again these two narratives are now at
war with one another so backing that
narrative yesterday was HR McMaster the
national security adviser he says that
the the people who leaked the story
another story from last week that the
president Trump had given intelligence
information classified information to
the Russians in this meeting just
offhand he said that the week of that
information is really what's dangerous
not from giving it to the Russians
I think the real issue and I think what
I'd like to see really debated more is
our national security has been put at
risk by those violating confidentiality
and those releasing information to the
press that that can be used connected
with other information available to make
American citizens and others more
vulnerable on the rider very upset with
the leaks people are saying this is
totally inappropriate because of the
leaks that's what's really dangerous
here it's the effort to get Trump that's
dangerous from inside his own
administration it is not Trump himself
who is dangerous and this is all just a
manufactured case against Trump and
there's a lot of truth to this okay
like for example on the Comey thing if
what Trump said to Comey was in fact
obstruction of justice why didn't Comey
just quit the most self-righteous man in
America is James Comey
most self flattering man in America is
James Comey except for President Trump
why wouldn't he just quit why wouldn't
he walk out of the Oval Office and say
to the press guys I had to leave because
Trump clearly wants to obstruct justice
as Mike Flynn thing and I can't be
around to be part of that obstruction of
justice why didn't he at least announce
it why didn't he Lee say anything this
is the argument that's being made from
the right and there's a lot of truth to
this there's a lot of truth to this so
again we have these dueling narratives
we're going to talk in a second about
which of the dueling narratives is more
important which one is right and what
the impact is going to be on politics
for the next couple of years because
Republicans have have a conundrum on
their hands Democrats can just keep
campaigning against Trump and
Republicans have a conundrum on their
hands we'll talk about all that in just
a second but first I want to say thank
you to our friends over at my Patriot
supply so if everything feels chaotic
right now if you like North Korea is on
the verge of gaining a nuclear missile
that could hit the United States which
they sort of are if it feels like the
federal government is not capable of
taking care of you in a crisis which it
isn't if it feels like a natural
disaster would leave you and your family
unsafe that's why you need prepare with
been calm prepare with been calm eight
eight eight eight oh three fourteen
thirteen you got a four week emergency
food supply for just 99 bucks plus free
shipping in cases of Dombey apocalypse
you're going to be the one who is safe
because you're the one who actually
spent that ninety nine dollars like a
one-time charge guys for a four week
emergency food supply folks in the
office have tasted it they say that it
tastes like home cooking and again you
just put it on your shelf you forget
about it until there's an emergency and
then you don't have to worry about it
that's what prepare with been calm is
for four week emergency food supply for
just $99 eight eight eight eight oh
three fourteen thirteen prepare with
been calm every governmental agency says
that you should have a certain amount of
food on tap just in case of an emergency
and if even the government says they
can't take care of you you can guarantee
the government can't take care of you
that's why you need prepare with been
calm four-week emergency food supply for
99 bucks plus free shipping again that's
prepared with been calm okay so as part
of the Trump is a victim of a hit that's
out to get him Tucker Carlson was
pushing that last night he says this
whole Comey Flynn bombshell is not
really a bombshell it's just another
media hit job The Skeptical says the
retired Navy SEAL be quiet
screams the 33 year old news anchor
clapping her hands in rage how dare you
question the authorities in this case
the news media quote you cannot attack
the stellar reporters of CNN she says as
if this settles the debate now a lot of
cable panels have unfolded like this
recently and that is a shame because as
we noted earlier the world is a
very complicated place Washington
especially what you think is happening
often really isn't happening
okay so again I think there's some truth
to this the media are out to get Trump
there's no question that that's true
Dana Bash right he's on the left she
says the deep state is out to get Trump
and that's pretty clear from this New
York Times report and if you just take a
step back well just in the past 24 hours
right or wrong what this president has
done in his first hundred plus days
didn't before he came into office is
pick fights with the intelligence
community and now the law enforcement
community particularly the way never
mind that he fired James Comey but the
way in which he did it not giving him
the respect of actually telling him in
person or at least not having him find
out from cable news and so we know that
this is you know they talk about the
deep state well this these are
communities that are that have a lot of
loyalty within and know how to get back
even if you're the president of the
United States look how excited Dana Bash
is about all this and you can see that
the pundits are just overjoyed with all
of this which is why the right reacts to
the media by saying you guys we're
totally full of crap there's nothing
here here's an entire montage you're
pundits just saying impeachment
impeachment impeachment impeachment they
are obviously very excited about this
story and they want impeachment if these
allegations senator are true are we
getting closer and closer to the
possibility of yet another impeachment
process reluctantly wolf I I have to say
yes simply because obstruction of
justice is such a serious offense and I
say it with with sadness we already
nailed on the fact he fired the guy
afterwards for not playing ball with
them there's a lot of evidence here it
seems it would take a reasonable person
in the direction of perhaps wanting more
information but clearly we're on the
trail there to an impeachment I think
we're an impeachment territory really
the first time well I think that the
obstruction of justice was the number
one charge against Nixon that brought
him down obstruction of justice was the
number one charge against Bill Clinton
which led to his indictment the house he
won in the Senate and I think I'm a
laughs lawyer I cannot tell you what it
meets all the legal definitions but I
can tell you from a lay point of view it
looks like he was trying to impede the
investigation
he was using his power to do that and
when James Comey didn't go along with
him when he wasn't his boy he fired him
which I think is also relevant to the
question of what he was trying to do
you've got to identify and lay out for
the American public everything that he
has done these firings these obstruction
of justice etc etc and in the final
analysis Maxine Waters was right to god
impeaching I know higher Democratic
Party so that was nose wolf blitzer
Chris Matthews David Gorgon and Maxine
Waters also angus King senator from
Maine all saying that we are growing
close to impeachment so does this sound
like a produce narrative does this sound
like everybody's on the same page in the
Democratic Party it does and that's why
there are people on the right who are
saying this sounds like a conspiracy to
take down President Trump and there is
truth to that so I'm going to talk in a
minute about what's true and what's
false and where we stand in the
Republican Party as far as Trump in just
a second but first you're going to have
to go over to Daly wire.com and
subscribe for $8 a month you can become
a subscriber over at Daly wired.com if
again the annual subscription right now
then you get a free copy of Jeremy
borings great border film about it's a
Western modern Western cent on the
border of the Arroyo all about a rancher
trying to protect his land from drug
cartels using it as a thoroughfare for
drugs and human trafficking also if you
come a subscriber right now then you're
number 1 helping us out we always
appreciate it cost a lot of money to
actually produce the show but also it
makes certain that you can be a part of
the mailbag in a couple of days well
tomorrow actually we're going to do the
mailbag we're going to start bringing
you a Friday show as well which is very
exciting so go over to Daley where
comment subscribe or if you just want to
listen later go over to iTunes or
SoundCloud and subscribe there take a
listen and leave us a rating we always
appreciate it we are the largest
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
you